[Musik]
wusstet ihr eigentlich dass wir an
weihnachten 2021 ein ganz besonderes
jubiläum feiern konnten kein geringeres
als den dreißigsten jahrestag des falls
des kommunismus der sowjetunion am 25
dezember 1991 mit der damalige präsident
der sowjetunion michail gorbatschow die
folgende rede gott hat uns viel
geschenkt land erdöl gas und andere
natur reichtümer und auch viele
talentierte und kluge menschen muss
dabei leben unsere menschen schlechter
als in den anderen entwickelten ländern
wir bleiben sogar immer weiter hinter
ihnen zurück der grund dafür war schon
lange zu sehen die gesellschaft befand
sich in einer schlinge eines
bürokratischen kommando systems die
gesellschaft musste der ideologie dienen
und dabei die furchtbare lasters und
wettrüstens tragen die gesellschaft
gelangte an die grenze ihrer
möglichkeiten das land verlor immer mehr
an perspektive so konnte man nicht
weiterleben es musste alles und legend
verändert werden richtig reform in
dieser rede kündigte er nicht nur seinen
rücktritt ankündigte auch den zerfall
der sowjetunion an und das ende des
kommunismus denk mal kurz über den
stellenwert dieses einen moments für die
gesamte welt nach der kommunismus in der
udssr wurde weder durch einen
volksaufstand noch durch einen krieg
gestürzt es war der kommunistische
führer selbst der eines tages sagte
leute da haben erkannt dass das einfach
nicht funktioniert und dass wir
kapitalisten werden müssen also vor
weihnachten und guten rutsch wir sehen
uns dann im neuen jahr und viele von
euch hat jetzt gleich sagen wie
originell das haben sie bestimmt nicht
kommen sehen und tatsächlich ist es so
dass die sowjetunion bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt b zweit wichtig zur weltmacht
war nicht einmal die glühendsten
antikommunisten konnten sich vorstellen
dass der kommunismus eines tages unter
seinem eigenen gewicht zusammenbrechen
würde die frage lautet also wie konnte
es überhaupt so weit kommen welchen weg
muss das totalitäre system integriert
und hinter sich bringen bis es in sich
zusammenbrach und vielleicht die
wichtigste frage von allen ließe sich
das ganze nicht wiederholen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die sowjetunion ist ein bisschen wie
deine urgroßeltern man hat dir
vielleicht etwas über sie erzählt aber
du hast sie nie wirklich kennengelernt
oder hast nur wenige oder auch gar keine
erinnerungen an sie so geht es zumindest
den link unter uns welche die gnade der
späten geburt hatte ich gehöre nicht
dazu und kann mich noch sehr gut an den
kommunistischen mit den stasi terror das
lügens system und das wirtschaftliche
elend erinnern was wir aber sicher alle
wissen ist dass die udssr im zweiten
weltkrieg irgendwann mitgeholfen hat
nazi-deutschland zu besiegen und das
kann der kalte krieg mit den usa begann
der mit der auflösung ersterer endete
man sprach damals vom ende der
geschichte so als ob es von da an auf
der ganzen welt nichts anderes mehr gebe
als friede freude und eierkuchen
30 jahre später sind wir längst eines
besseren belehrt worden denn irgendwie
haben sich die verhältnisse verschoben
aber nicht wirklich geändert wieder
sitzen die ewiggestrigen am ruder
shipping sagt dies vor wut union sei
gefallen weil niemand manns genug war
gegen die usa aufzustehen und widerstand
zu leisten
okay wir wissen dass es in der udssr an
vielen dingen mangelte aber seine mal
erich testosteron gehörte sicher nicht
dazu alle die das sagen hatten waren
männer aber gut schießen ping war schon
2012 nur wenige monate bevor chinas
präsident wurde anderer meinung diese
entlarvende macho spruch ist nämlich
schon zehn jahre alt am ende dieses
videos werdet ihr genau verstehen warum
sich schiebe der verbreitung dieser
historischen lüge unter seinen
journalistischen anhängern und
landsleuten sein eigenes grab schaufelt
im grunde genommen in dieselbe falle
hineinläuft in die auch die führung der
kpd su getappt ist und ihr werdet auch
nachvollziehen können warum man die
geschichte der udssr kennen muss um den
krieg russlands gegen die ukraine und
die rolle chinas dabei im geopolitischen
und historischen kontext richtig
einzuordnen spitzt also die ohren denn
diesmal geht es wirklich darum echte
welt geschichte zu schreiben und die
weltordnung des kommenden jahrhundert zu
verstehen meiner regie und putin haben
uns italiener geopolitische die kopie
aufgezwungen die wir für längst
überwunden geglaubt hatten jene zwei
spaltung der welt in gut und böse der
doch alle entrinnen wollten nun müssen
wir uns wieder mit ihr beschäftigen ob
wir wollen oder nicht deshalb müssen wir
auch in die geschichte zurückblicken um
aus ihr zu lernen lasst uns also über
die udssr sprechen
[Musik]
wir wollen eine bilanz des sowjetischen
kommunismus zu seinen errungenschaften
anerkennen und den ist tatsächlich ein
vergabe und auf seinen zahlreichen
fehler hinweisen natürlich werden wir in
diesem video mehr als 80 jahre
geschichte in ein paar minuten
zusammenfassen müssen weswegen wir
natürlich nicht auf alle details
eingehen können also werden wir uns
heute besonders auf eine frage
konzentrieren warum scheiterte der real
existierendes sowjetischen kommunismus
was war der grund dafür dass am 25
dezember note mit einem 90 der präsident
einer der größten supermächte der welt
zurücktrat und einen kompletten wechsel
des politischen systems ankündigte und
woran scheiterten gorbatschows reformen
heute werden wir im rahmen eines visual
politik sowie specials all diese fragen
beantworten dazu werden wir natürlich
erst mal einen blick in die geschichte
bevor wir jedoch los legen möchten wir
uns bei euch bedanken uns hat ganz ganz
doll gedanken mit eurer hilfe haben wir
vor kurzem einen wichtigen meilenstein
100.000 abonnenten erreicht und ja ich
weiß wir versprechen euch schon seit den
50001 hintergrund special bei uns um
unsere arbeit die aktuellen geschehnisse
in der welt bringen uns jedoch jeden tag
die wichtigere themen auf den tisch als
ein nettes selbstbeweihräucherung video
habt also bitte noch etwas geduld
einverstanden vielleicht werde ja in der
zwischenzeit so nett uns mit den
nächsten hundert tausend abonnenten zu
helfen und ich habe dazu schon eine
kleine idee erwähnt doch mal öfter in
den kommentarbereich und anderer kanäle
und medien die er gerne verfolgt dass es
uns gibt und die unsere videos toll
findet natürlich immer schön
themenbezogen konstruktiv und höflich
kein of pop ikone tonne bitte wir wollen
ja nur dass noch viele weitere menschen
die sich für unsere themen interessieren
und muss erfahren und dann auch in den
genuss unserer videos kommen können
lasst uns also die erreichten erfolge
ganz standesgemäß feiern mit ehrlicher
arbeit und aufrichtigen engagement so
und nun ab in die tiefen der
sowjetischen geschichte
eine supermacht wert geboren
im jahr 1929 litten die usa unter der
großen depression während die gesamte
kapitalistische welt in einer heftigen
wirtschaftskrise steckte erlebte der
kommunistischen osten jedoch sein
goldenes zeitalter
ja genau russland wandelte sich zu
dieser zeit von einem fast
mittelalterlichen und agrar
wirtschaftlich geprägten land zu einer
industrie macht manche schätzungen
behaupten sogar dass die sowjetunion zu
dieser zeit eines der am schnellsten
wachsenden länder der welt war und ja
ich sage schätzungen denn das
bruttoinlandsprodukt wurde erst ab 1937
als makroökonomische indikator verwendet
aber das ist eine andere geschichte auf
jeden fall war russland damals aber
richtig on fire
aber wie war das möglich geworden so der
kommunismus nicht nicht funktionieren
nun überlegt mal es gibt noch etwas viel
schlimmeres als kommunismus und das ist
die vollkommen absenz eines
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
systems überhaupt bis zur russischen
revolution beschränkt sich die zahlen
darauf von einem krieg in den nächsten
zu ziehen ihr reich war ein riesiges
schneeballsystem das nur auf permanente
expansion und aus produkt anderer
bedrohte eines der schrecklichsten
kolonial imperien dessen greuel jedoch
merkwürdigerweise von der selektiven
geschichtsschreibung und so gut wie
allen moralisten in ost und west die so
gerne mit der historischen schuld bis
ein oder andere volkes argumentieren
komplett ignoriert wird ähnlich sieht es
ja auch mit dem arabischen imperialismus
und sklavenhandel aus man spricht
einfach nicht darüber passt halt nicht
ins weltbild ist aber eine andere
geschichte also zurück ist zarenreich
damit die zahlen ihre kriege finanzieren
konnten muss natürlich der rubel rollen
das heißt die zaren drucken geld ohne
ende und preston ihre untertanen durch
die erhebung von steuern kräftig aus
nach der oktoberrevolution kamen die
kommunisten an die macht und der stadt
begangen all das geld welches er
einnahmen von echte investitionen zu
verwenden plötzlich konnten die russen
ihre bildung infrastruktur und
produktionssysteme modernisieren
das zentralisierte wirtschaftssystem
verlagerte ressourcen vom land in die
städte dies soll jetzt glaubten dass die
industrialisierung in großem maßstab
verstanden gehen musste um erfolgreich
zu sein klotzen statt kleckern war
angesagt mit allen nebeneffekten das so
mit sich bringt an erster stelle stand
die steigerung der produktivität denn
die fabriken sollten produktiv genug
sein um die hohen investitionskosten für
ihren bau zu rechtfertigen deshalb stieg
nach stars erste fünf-jahres- plan im
jahr 1928 das in die industrialisierung
des landes investierte kapital um
sagenhafte
336 prozent die zahl der bauern die von
ihren höfen vertrieben und in die
industrie integriert wurde bestimmung
fast 190 prozent all dies wird erst mal
zu guten ergebnissen auch wenn diese
leicht hinter den erwartungen
zurückblieben die industrieproduktion
stieg um 170 prozent und stalin sagte
damals das gleiche wie diese weißbärtige
typ in jurassic park ich habe keine
kosten gescheut tja und dann brachten
die dinos aus ihren käfigen aber jetzt
sehen wir uns erst mal an wie dieser so
wird park überhaupt aussah
[Musik]
ein erstes problem war zum beispiel dass
die kollektivierung der landwirtschaft
nicht funktioniert hat salih versuchte
der landwirtschaft mit gewalt ressourcen
zu entreißen und das führte in die
katastrophe er vernichtete die kulaken
die wohlhabendsten erfahrensten bauern
und verstaatlichte diktiere was dazu
führte dass diese von den bauern
geschlachtet wurden das ergebnis sprach
für sich die landwirtschaftliche
produktion ging im vergleich zum 128 und
mehr als ein viertel zurück aber das
darlehen gehört nicht gerade zu jeder
sorte von herrschern die sagen wir mal
mit kritik konstruktiv umgehen konnten
die repression waren fürchterlich und
führten zu einem völkermord der in
seinem ausmaß mit denen der nazis und
mao tse tungs vergleichbar ist laut
einer großen sowjetischen zeitung vielen
20 millionen menschen stalin zum opfer
so stylings verbrechen während dieser
zeit gehört auch der holodomor die
gezielte aushungerung der
landbevölkerung vor allem in der ukraine
und in kasachstan dieses epochale trauma
steckt den menschen in der ukraine auch
heute noch nach mehreren generationen
tief in den knochen daher ist der
widerstand dagegen wieder aus moskau
beherrscht zu werden so gewaltig es ist
die ukrainische version des nie wieder
aber das sollten wir ein eigenes video
machen das schlimmste an den 1930 er
jahren war aber dass du praktisch ein
niemand warst wenn du nicht in ein
anderes land einmarschiert bist
angriffskriege gehörten einfach zum
guten ton unter den diktaturen europas
und dieser finstere club gab damals
absolut den ton an denn es gab zu dieser
zeit in kontinentaleuropa kaum
funktionierende demokratien stalin
fühlte sich also unter seinesgleichen
und hielt es für eine super idee den
molotow ribbentrop pakt mit
nazi-deutschland zu unterzeichnen um
polen in zwei hälften zu teilen und die
baltischen republiken zu annektieren und
bessarabien das wort ihre moldawien zu
besetzen doch dann verriet ihn sein
schnauzbart kumpel hitler und tickte
beinahe die sowjetunion von der
landkarte denn zuvor hatte stalin eine
brutale säuberungsaktion innerhalb der
roten armee durchgeführt und praktisch
alle spitzen kann man büro liquidiert
nur dank der massiven materielle
finanzielle und logistische hilfe der
usa hatten die sowjets überhaupt eine
chance die brutalen nazi ehre
aufzuhalten zu besiegen und schließlich
so einer der beiden großen supermächte
der welt aufzusteigen der dank dafür sie
begannen den kalten krieg und hielten
ost und mitteleuropa jahrzehntelang den
willen der dortigen völker besetzt in
guter alter touristischer tradition
vom höhepunkt bis zum zusammenbruch
das folgende statement habt ihr sicher
schon alle mal gehört der sowjet
kommunismus hat nicht funktioniert weil
die menschen keinen anreiz zu arbeiten
hatten und irgendwie stimmt das aber
gleichzeitig auch wieder nicht wenn wir
unseren englischen schwester karl may
prozess verfolgt werdet ihr mit vielen
des sowjetischen durchbrüche bereits
vertraut seien die sowjetunion konnte
sie der brillantesten der geschichte
verweisen in den ersten jahren des space
race war russland den usa sogar weit
voraus damals herrschte im westen ein
ähnliches gefühl wie heute in bezug auf
china es gab die befürchtung dass die
sowjets die usa und generell die
kapitalistische welt wirtschaftlich und
militärisch überholen würden überlegt
mal es gab keine informationen darüber
was auf der anderen seite des eisernen
vorhangs geschah und die sowjetische
zensur maschinerie war sehr gut darin
ihre misserfolge und schändlichen taten
zu vertuschen denn tatsächlich gab es
jede menge schande zu verbergen
man könnte sagen dass den sowjetischen
kommunismus bitte der 1960 er jahre
langsam die luft ausgehen bis zur
entdeckung von erdöl in sibirien was der
kommunistischen partei eine kurze
atempause verschaffte
das problem der sowjetischen
wirtschaftler auf jeden fall dass ich
eine sehr geringe produktivität auf die
es die udssr stagnierte in den siebziger
jahren und jetzt werdet ihr euch fragen
warum wo lag das problem und hier kommt
einer der wenigen
wirtschaftswissenschaftler ins spiel der
den zusammenbruch des sowjetkommunismus
richtig prophezeit hat und zwar mehrere
jahrzehnte bevor es passiert
die rede ist von ludwig von mises in
seinem werk die gemeinwirtschaft
untersuchungen über den sozialismus
erklärt dieses die wichtigsten
unterschiede zwischen einer
zentralistischen und einer freien
marktwirtschaft in einer freien
marktwirtschaft stellen viele
unternehmer unabhängig voneinander
ineffizienzen fest und müssen versuchen
lösungen dafür zu finden einige von
ihnen finden die richtigen lösungen und
werden reich andere wiederum scheitern
daran und verschwinden von der
landfläche aber im allgemeinen tendiert
das kapital dazu sich in den
effizientesten sektoren zu konzentrieren
und woher weiß man welche sektoren die
effizientesten sind durch das
preissystem wenn ich sehe deshalb preis
einer ware oder dienstleistung
vergleichsweise hoch ist dann liegt es
wahrscheinlich daran dass die nachfrage
danach zu groß ist also besteht bedarf
nach mehr angebot logisch oder in einer
zentralistischen wirtschaft wird das
kapital jedoch nicht von vielen akteuren
und nach wirtschaftlichen sondern nach
politischen kriterien und zentral
verteilt das heißt der staat kann in
sektoren investieren die nicht unbedingt
die effizientesten sind
[Musik]
und das erklärt auch warum ein
landwirtschaftliches regime auf kurze
sicht durchaus erfolgreich sein kann der
staat gibt als übermächtiger akteur
endlich aus es ist möglich
beeindruckende großprojekte zu stemmen
und er kann sogar branche schaffen die
sonst undenkbar wären bist du ein
beispiel nehmen wir etwa die
schwerindustrie in einem land wie der
sowjetunion dass sich gerade auf dem weg
vom agrarstaat zu industrienationen
befindet ohne die durch die staat
gelenkte konzentration aller mittel auf
diese eine aufgabe wäre sie sicher nicht
so schnell möglich gewesen wo liegt also
das problem nun auf lange sicht treten
wieder viele generelle mängel auf die
unentdeckt bleiben und nicht bereinigt
werden weil es keinen wettbewerb gibt
uns die summieren sich mit der zeit zu
einem riesigen unkontrollierten haufen
von fehlallokation ich gebe euch ein
beispiel die geschichte des aralsees
der aralsee war einst eine der vier
größten seen der welt den 1960 er jahren
leitete die sowjetunion eine menge
wasser um damit baumwollfeldern mit dem
ganzen wasser versorgt werden konnten
ein solches projekt wäre in einem
kapitalistischen land praktisch
unmöglich gewesen der staat hätte einen
jahrelangen rechtsstreit führen müssen
die dazu notwendigen grundstück
enteignen zu können der preis vor allem
das land liga so teuer gewesen dass nur
ein viel kleinerer umfang realisierbar
gewesen wäre von protesten und klagen
durch umweltschützer mal ganz zu
schweigen doch in einem kommunistischen
system ist alles land staatseigentum
privateigentum also beschloss jemand von
seinem moskauer schreibtisch aus dass
sprichwörtlich über nacht eine mega
wasser umleitung gebaut werden sollen
und nichts konnte sich diesen
größenwahnsinnigen plan in den weg
stellen das ergebnis in den nächsten 60
jahren schrumpfte der see auch nur etwas
mehr als zehn prozent seiner
ursprünglichen größe und zur
ökologischen katastrophe kam noch eine
wirtschaftliche hinzu was ein perfektes
anbaugebiete sein können ist jetzt
praktisch eine wüste und jetzt stellt
euch vor dass dies nur ein beispiel ist
welches sich jedoch in einem solchen
system tausendfach in vielen anderen
fällen wiederholt und die geschichte der
sowjetunion ist eine geschichte vieler
größten basel megaprojekte
städte wie magnitogorsk zum beispiel
sind über nacht entstanden und viele
dieser projekte müssen auf den ersten
blick nicht unbedingt schlechte ideen
gewesen sein das problem war aber dass
der staat ohne ein funktionierendes
preissysteme nicht operieren konnte wie
viel investiert werden musste um
wirklich wirtschaftlich sinnvoll zu
agieren niemand in einem zentralen büro
kann so schlau sein wie ganz ganz viele
unabhängige marktteilnehmer hinzu kamen
die fehlende meinungsfreiheit in diesen
streng hierarchischen strukturen wagte
ist niemand auf die unzulänglichkeiten
hinzuweisen sonst urlaub jemand der sich
an seine allmacht gewöhnt hat verliert
mit der zeit immer mehr die gabe
schlechte nachrichten die einen reißer
erwachsener mensch zu ertragen und zu
verdauen diese problematik ist
systemisch und nicht reformierbar und so
kam es wie es kommen musste was einst
eine der am schnellsten wachsenden
volkswirtschaften der welt war stadt
ihre schließlich nach erinnert euch das
nicht an eine andere pseudo
kommunistische großmacht
[Musik]
verstehe jetzt warum schießt mythos die
führung der udssr sei einfach nicht
manns genug gewesen gegen die usa
aufzustehen und widerstand zu leisten so
gefährlich ist sie züchtet in china
ebenfalls ein system der intransparenz
aus dicht geknüpften lügen und
zwanghafter kontrolle heran kritiker
werfen ihr model weggesperrt und sozial
lobotomie rdx damit wir uns nicht falsch
verstehen üben propaganda und harte wie
weiche zensur werden auch vom
demokratischen westen eingesetzt denn
diese mittel liegen einfach in der natur
des menschen wer hat in seinem leben
noch nie gelogen oder eine unbequeme
wahrheit ignoriert der schlüssel zum
erfolg liegt jedoch in maß und
kalibrierung in der systemischen
fähigkeit eine optimale balance zwischen
lüge und wahrheit zwischen illusion und
realität vereinigung zu erreichen es ist
eine permanente gratwanderung ohne
illusionen haben die menschen keine
hoffnungen keine vision ohne
realitätswahrnehmung sind sie nicht in
der lage ihre fehler zu korrigieren
und wer das bessere system einer
ganzheitlichen nachhaltigen selbst
korrigierenden illusionen von freiheit
und selbstbestimmung ausbauen kann der
wind jedoch überdehnt die einzig sowie
tanzen das sich in geld raus befindende
neureiche china durch innere wie äußere
konflikte die es nicht gewinnen kann da
sie auf krassen fehleinschätzungen
basieren er hat das noch verlogene putin
russland zu seinem was hallen statt
gemacht einem anhängsel und proxy chinas
über welchen er nun in der ukraine einen
stellvertreterkrieg gegen die nato zu
führen glaubt man muss sich dazu nur die
staatlichen medien chinas und die filter
der dortigen zensoren ansehen um das
spielchen zu durchschauen peking setzt
im eigenen land knallhart dasselbe
narrativ über den ukraine krieg durch
dass auch moskau herbei liegt es handle
sich nur um eine spezialoperation zur
entnazifizierung der ukraine die
russischen soldaten würden das
zivilbevölkerung kein haar krümmen und
so weiter und so fort damit keine
missverständnisse aufkommen
dies ist die vorgegebene linie der kp
chinas nicht die meinung des ganzen
chinesischen volkes in denen das ganze
durchaus kontrovers gesehen wird das
alles ist sehr traurig für china und
noch trauriger für russland einst weiß
doch die sowjetunion die als weltmacht
arme kleine staaten zu proxies
degradiert hat um über sie dreckige
stellvertreterkriege zu führen nun sind
die ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken russland
und die ukraine selbst zu solchen
proxies herabgesunken der unterschied
zwischen den beiden ist jedoch dass die
menschen in der ukraine gut wissen und
auch immer wieder betonen dass sie
diesen trick stellvertretend für die
ganze freie welt kämpfen während die
russen wodka und propaganda vernebelt
noch immer glauben sie seien 12 verena
start
sie hat putin zu einem nützlichen
idioten gemacht aber moment mal wenn
putin jetzt selbst ein nützlicher idiot
ist was sind dann putins nützliche
idioten nützliche idioten hoch zwei also
ich meine all jene putin verstehe und
verharmlose im westen die uns noch immer
mit groben erklärungen weiß zu machen
versuchen es sei der westen gewesen der
aus putin jeden massen oder gemacht habe
als der er sich nun offen entpuppt hätte
entpuppt echt jetzt putins erste
amtshandlung nachdem er 1999 zum
ministerpräsidenten ernannt wurde war
die anordnung gezielter
flächenbombardements gegen die
zivilbevölkerung in tschetschenien bis
zu 80.000 zivile opfer waren das
ergebnis das war vor 23 jahren es
folgten unzählige morde an journalisten
oppositionellen und anderen kritikern
und jetzt wollen sie uns allen ernstes
mehr oder minder versteckt den mythos
unterschieden erst der westen hätte ihn
zum massenmörder gemacht klar sie wollen
auch vom eigenen versagen ablenken und
davon dass sie die ganze zeit aufs
falsche pferd gesetzt haben genauso wie
china dass er auch auf den falschen
proxy gesetzt hat und auf sein
versprechen eines reibungslosen
blitzkrieg peking hat sich mit diesen
gravierenden fehler in seiner
geopolitischen strategie geradewegs auf
dieselbe bahn gegeben welche auch das
combat union 1 1 geschlagen hatte und
die sie schließlich in den untergang
führte
[Applaus]
aber vorsicht so ein koloss kann sehr
sehr lange dauern die udssr bekannt zum
beispiel unverhofft eine weitere
gnadenfrist die ölpreiskrise von 1979
ließ die rohölpreise in die höhe
schießen was der sowjetischen wirtschaft
eine ordentliche menge dollars
einbrachte davon wiederum war das
politbüro so begeistert dass jemand im
kreml es für eine gute idee hielt mit
dem neu erlangten geld in afghanistan
einzumarschieren
heute wissen wir bereits dass es
eigentlich egal ist ob man versucht den
hindukusch zu beherrschen oder lieber
gleich von der klippe springt auf die
sowjets sind der afghanischen falle
nicht entkommen plötzlich waren sie in
einer unendlichen spirale explodieren
der militärausgaben gefangen aber
achtung das war nicht nur die schulter
afghanen auch ronald reagan hatte eine
menge damit zu tun liegen und
manipulierte star wars tests haben den
kreml getäuscht und sogar den
us-kongress gut er war nicht so mächtig
wie der todesstern aber der
hollywood-schauspieler regeln erfand
einen weltraum schild welcher die usa
angeblich vor einem atomangriff schützen
konnte und das double in panik die
kommunistische führung gab millionen
abermillionen aus um etwas nachzubauen
was schlichtweg unmöglich war denn das
angebliche projekt der usa war nichts
als ein großes schauspiel wir haben
diese geschichte schon einmal in einem
anderen video ausführlich gebracht und
ich werde es euch unten verlinkt und
traders trick brachte in verbindung mit
dem reaktorunfall in tschernobyl
ebenfalls ein produkt des politischen
schlendrian lügens systems der
wirtschaft der udssr schließlich den
absoluten rui und die frage die damals
im raum stand war klipp und klar war es
schon zu spät und zu versuchen die
sowjetunion zu reformieren genau das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal genauer an
troika
die sowjetunion wurde anfang der 1980 er
jahre von einer alten ergrauten und
erstarrten guard reagiert sie war zu
einer ausgewachsenen geronto kratie
geworden das durchschnittsalter der
mitglieder des politbüros lag bei sage
und schreibe 70 jahren während die
damalige lebenserwartung eines
politischen mannes bei nur 62 jahren lag
überlegt mal eine sekunde welche
erbärmliche traurigkeit diesen beiden
zahlen steckt übrigens zum zeitpunkt von
stalins tod betrug das
durchschnittsalter des politbüros
immerhin noch 55 jahre und ihr könnt mir
vertrauen lebenserfahrung ist oft ein
großer vorteil aber sie birgt auch
risiken innerhalb von weniger als drei
jahren starten drei generalsekretäre der
kommunistischen partei drei andere pop
und chill janko
[Musik]
das regime zeigte also allein schon aus
biologischer gesetzmäßigkeit deutliche
anzeichen des zusammenbruchs die
eingeschränkte realitätswahrnehmung der
alten männer war immer stärker zu spüren
und ihr kontrollverlust bei
gleichzeitiger kontrollsucht war immens
zum beispiel wurde der kreml von
grassierender korruption angesucht nach
bereichen jetzt tod kam der sogenannte
baumwoll skandal ans licht in denen
eines der hohen tiere des politbüros
direkt verwickelt waren die aufdeckung
dieses gigantischen betrugs korruption
und bereicherung im ganz großen stil
öffnete den menschen in der udssr den
augen den beklagenswerten zustand der
wirtschaft in ihrem land aber diese
geschichte hätte eine ganz eigenes video
verdient also aber nicht vergessen und
keines unserer künftigen videos zu
verpassen wer heutzutage im westen kaum
noch bekannte baumburg skandal war aber
ganz und gar kein einzelfall die
korruption der kommunistischen führung
konnte selbst durch die strengste zensur
nicht mehr vertuscht werden
[Musik]
die reformer innerhalb der partei hatten
also eine lange liste von gründen als
sie 1985 die ernennung von michael
gorbatschow zum generalsekretär des
zentralkomitees der kp bsu durchsetzen
mit 54 jahren hatte er für das sowjet
verhältnisse gerade mal seine pubertät
hinter sich und wollte unbedingt etwas
verändern er versuchte auch mit aller
kraft seine reformpläne umgehend in die
tat umzusetzen aber er kam einfach zu
spät der schlimmste atomunfall der
geschichte das reaktorunglück von
tschernobyl machte alle hoffnungen
zunichte durch diese katastrophe und ihr
handling wurde einmal mehr die mangelnde
transparenz der sowjetischen behörden
deutlich und 20 jahre nach der
katastrophe war sich gorbatschow darüber
selbst vollkommen im klaren
die kernschmelze in tschernobyl war
vielleicht sogar noch mehr als meine
einführung der perestroika die
hauptursache für den zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion fünf jahre später die
vertuschung von tschernobyl war für die
udssr fatalis politischen hürden braucht
mehrere tage bis sie den gau zugaben die
ersten informationen über die
katastrophe kamen aus schweden wollen
anstieg der radioaktivität festgestellt
wurde das hat das zu bedeuten dass die
menschen in der ukraine und im übrigen
osteuropa ihrem normalen leben nachgehen
ohne auch nur die leiseste ahnung davon
zu haben dass sie schutzlos der
radioaktiven wolke ausgesetzt waren das
genaue ausmaß diese unverantwortlichen
zensurmaßnahme bis nicht nur schwer
beziffern seriöse schätzungen gehen
insgesamt von zwischen 4000 und 60.000
toten bis heute aus also ja zensur kann
menschen töten
gorbatschow war dies ein zeichen dafür
dass das politische system noch
greifende reformen brauchte als jene die
bereits im gang waren diese würden unter
dem schlagwort perestroika durchgeführt
was auf russisch umgestaltung bedeutet
sie umfasst eine reihe von maßnahmen zur
allmählichen liberalisierung der
wirtschaft und des politischen systems
es wurden schritte in richtung eines
begrenzten freien marktes um eine
dezentralisierung der sowjetischen
wirtschaft unternommen ein wichtiger
teil dieser reformen war glasnost was
transparenz bedeutet die presse und das
fernsehen begannen positionen zu
verbreiten die der traditionell starke
auslegung des sozialistischen projekt
zuwiderliefen all dies würde zum relativ
freien wahl im jahre 1989 die endgültig
zeigten dass sich die kommunistische
parteien den augen der menschen
vollkommen diskreditiert hatte die
sowjetischen wähler versetzten den
parteifunktionären einem demütigenden
schlag der fall der berliner mauer ende
1989 war das erste anzeichen dafür dass
der kommunistische blog zu zerbröckeln
begangen und im laufe des jahres 1990
fanden in jede der 15 sozialistischen
forget republiken parlamentswahlen statt
zum ersten mal hatte die opposition die
möglichkeit all das endlich zu sagen was
das politbüro der kommunistischen partei
in kreml nicht hören wollte damit war
nun die gelegenheit gekommen auf welche
die nationalisten in die suite
republiken so lange gewartet hatten
[Musik]
die drei baltischen staaten estland
lettland und litauen und warteten keine
sekunde lang um ihren weg in die
unabhängigkeit zu suchen und auch andere
teile des riesenreichs beanspruchten
ihre eigene souveränität allen voran die
russische sowjet republik unter der
führung von boris jelzin der countdown
zum zerfall der udssr hatte begonnen im
august 1991 begann sich die spirale noch
schneller zu drehen ein staatsstreich
der vom kgb und dem herd gelände der
kommunistischen partei durchgeführt
wurde scheiterte kläglich das letzte
gewaltsame aufbäumen eines gescheiterten
anachronistischen systems erst gab es
kein zurück mehr die sozialistischen
sowjetrepubliken beschlossen sich von
der udssr zu trennen und in seiner
rücktrittsrede als präsident der
sowjetunion verwies gorbatschow auf das
absolute scheitern des kommunismus
gott hat uns viel geschenkt land erdöl
gas und andere natur reichtümer und auch
viele talentierte und kluge menschen und
dabei neben unsere menschen schlechter
als in den anderen entwickelten ländern
wir bleiben sogar immer weiter hinter
ihnen zurück der grund dafür war schon
lange zu sehen die gesellschaft befand
sich in einer schlinge eines
bürokratischen kommandos systems die
gesellschaft musste der ideologie dienen
und dabei die furchtbare lasters
wettrüstens tragen die gesellschaft
gelangte an die grenze ihrer
möglichkeiten das land verlor immer mehr
an perspektive so konnte man nicht
weiterleben es musste alles und legend
verändert werden
die auflösung der sowjetunion war dabei
das letzte was gorbatschow ursprünglich
wollte er hatte geglaubt dass das
kommunistische regime eine chance gehabt
hätte zu einer sozialdemokratin
überzugehen welche die unterstützung des
volkes genießen würde aber wenn man den
leuten nach jahrzehnten unter dem loch
des sowjetsystems die chance gibt sich
zu äußern wollen sie nur eines sie
wollen freiheit so viel davon wie nur
möglich all das nachholen was ihnen so
lange verwehrt wurde man musste der
wahrheit ins auge blicken die
sowjetunion konnte nicht reformiert
werden
[Musik]
am 25 dezember 1991 wurde am kreml die
rote flagge mit hammer und sichel
eingeholt an ihrer stelle rede nun die
trikolore der russischen föderation und
viele von euch werden sich nach dieser
aufregenden geschichte fragen wie geht
es weiter und hat sich russland im
kapitalismus wirklich gut entwickelt nun
ja darüber werden wir in einem weiteren
video sprechen dass wir schon meister
öffentlicht werden darin werden wir
zeigen die aus dem hoffnungsvollen
anstrengung wieder das grauenvolles
system putin entstehen konnte welches
den seit dem ende des zarenreichs
fortschreitenden zerfallsprozess
russlands fortführt leonid gilead
streichen der vater in den siebziger
jahren mit seinen realitätsverlust und
seinem expansionistischen abenteuer die
sowjetunion überdehnt und damit ihren
untergang vorprogrammiert wladimir
wladimirowitsch putin ist am 24
2022 in seine fußstapfen getreten aber
in der zwischenzeit seid ihr an der
reihe glaubt ihr die sowjetunion hätte
ihren zusammenbruch verhindern können
und noch wichtiger was haltet ihr von
gorbatschows war er wirklich der held
der demokratie als denen viele
darstellen oder war einfach nur ein
opfer der ereignisse die immer sind auf
eure meinungen in den kommentaren schon
sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
projekt was dabei gelernt habt was ja
gibt ein like teilt es mit uns freunden
und vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen
und keines unserer videos zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mädels hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen dem rapper
link dazu findet jeder beschreibung oder
die video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]